now there in December we can finally
start celebrating the season the season
where we can catch up with that old man
with a white beard reveling some of the
magic and enjoy the green and red colors
that accompany this time of year wait
you thought there was some other event
happening this time of year that's right
this December brings us another Star
Wars and with Rowan's release imminent
fans have been speculating left right
and center on what new info this new
Star Wars spin-off will give us so here
are the five wildest rogue on fan
theories about the new squad of
scoundrels
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the question that's been
plaguing Star Wars fans for years how on
earth could the Death Star be destroyed
so easily sure Luke's got the force shot
was one in a million yadda yadda but why
the flip does the Death Star have such a
giant Achilles heel in the first place
well
reddit user opus diddy double-oh-seven
interesting name thinks that rogue one
may give us the answer
he thinks the Jin's father the famed
scientist Galen air so put it there
here's his reasoning the Essos lived in
captivity until they were rescued by
orson cranek an old friend of gaylen's
and member of the republic flash Empires
desktop project Jin ended up being
separated from her parents and doesn't
hear anything from them until years
later the rebels go full genes reunited
calm and managed to intercept the
transmission from one Galen Urso who
says that a major weapons test is
imminent
you know the planet destroying Death
Star variety of major weapons testing
while Jin thinks that her father built
Death Star could it actually be that he
sabotaged it to in one trailer we hear
the lovely Mads Mikkelsen saying
whatever I do
I do I detect you sure he'd be terrible
at singing Bryan Adams at karaoke but he
might have just given the rebels a
chance top dad
[Music]
in a bid to tie together the sequel
trilogy with the spin-off series of
movies ready to read like gamers
read like gamers this is a movie theory
not a game theory names not read like
movies jeez anyway red light poses the
theory that this squadron of rebels
actually become the Knights of Ren
further down the road the meat of this
theory comes from comparisons between
this promo image for rogue one and the
force awakens concept art for the
Knights of Ren right so let's break down
the five rebels versus the five nights
firstly Donnie yen's badass character
sure it's my has been paired with a
knife called monk as red light compares
his appearance to that of a Tibetan monk
and both utilize staffs in combat phase
Malibu's has the bearing of a heavy
weapons trooper with armor and a large
blaster so he is a shoo-in for the
knight labelled as the heavy
then there's diego luna's casseon and/or
who is carrying a rifle round in both
the promo image and some freighter
scenes super seems fit for the role of
the knight labeled sniper the knight
named the armory has been connected with
Bodie rook as both spoke plenty of
gadgets and matching goggles and lastly
as the leader of the rebellious Bunch it
only makes sense that Jenner so holds
the title of the night rogue thankfully
there are some more connections rather
than just the physical similarities
between the two groups in Forest
Whitaker's speech in the trailer it
implies there's a risk of the rebels
being captured and broken up if you
continue to fight
what will you become perhaps implying
the Vader of Sidious mentally brakes or
mind washes the roads into joining the
Empire whether this is a legitimate
connection or not I'll let you guys
decide I just hope they're way less
inner than their leader there's been an
awakening
this next theory could be the bridge
between rogue one and the new trilogy
the theory linking the two together was
put forward by snaky one one three who
posits the supreme leader snoke the
malevolent oversized bad dude seen in
the force awakens will actually appear
in rogue one how you ask well in the
trailers eagle-eyed fans have spotted a
back to tank a device which is used to
accelerate healing and not seen since
Luke took a Whomper to the face in
Empire Strikes Back the theory is that
Snoke is inside that tank and therefore
likely to make an appearance in rogue
one however this theory starts to fall
apart thanks to his reliance on the idea
that Snoke is Darth Plagueis the master
of Darth Sidious who you may remember to
be Emperor Palpatine stay with me here
so Plagueis is known to be so powerful
that he was capable of using the Force
to extend his lifespan and effectively
become immortal except he was eventually
killed by his own apprentice as darkside
apprentices are inclined to do so why
would Palpatine keep him around and put
him in a healing tank
well sneaky-sneaky theory says it could
be because he's just an evil son of a
gun and once the rebel in his victory by
using his master as a trophy however a
likely a theory suggests that Palpatine
needed the secrets to Plagueis his life
extending force abilities and so had to
keep him around
unfortunately lucasfilm's creative
executive Pablo Hidalgo who loves
crushing fan dreams by debunking
theories has thoroughly kicked this one
to the curb firstly he said Plagueis
could keep his loved ones from dying not
himself
and secondly that Plagueis is 100% mega
dead and thus not Snoke nevertheless
that doesn't mean Snoke can't be in
rogue one as noted by Star Wars fans the
galaxy over in the force awakens Snoke
says he's watched the Galactic Empire
rise and then fall which means he was
around during the original trilogy in
some capacity perhaps skulking around
even further back than that the first
order rose from the dark side
you did not lor San Tekka was in the
force awakens' for a hot minute that was
before we got chopped into hot minute
steaks come on you know who I'm talking
about Max von Sydow the guy who gave Poe
Dameron the map to Luke Skywalker but
three-eyed Raven from Game of Thrones
yeah there you go there's gotta be more
to teca's and reddit user be on in eight
cachi thinks that rogue one could be the
movie to give us some answers
we know bits about TECA from official
Star Wars Gump his character bio on
starwars.com states that he helped Luke
Skywalker retrieve ancient Jedi law
after the Battle of Endor so they could
have got pally and that's when Luke
entrusted tecar with the map to find him
which explains his tie to the male
Skywalker twin and while a ascends poe
dameron to go and find him but how close
are teca's and lair
well close enough that tech is clearly
Revere's lair for her princess status
and not for her generals rank burnin
eight sure why not believes that a
younger version of TECA will appear in
rogue one as one of the rebels that
helped steal the deaths are plans that
would certainly make him an old ally of
layers which is how he knows all about
Ren's Jerry Springer family drama I mean
we'll have to wait and see the film to
find out but come on he's an old dude he
could have been around for the events of
rogue one and I mean if not then me and
Ben and I are gonna look dumb as [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the theory that has the highest
probability of coming into fruition jyn
erso the protagonist of Rohan is
force-sensitive this theory was recently
strengthened in rogue once Trust trailer
during which a young Jin is told to
trust in the force by a lady that is
believed to be her mother later on Jin
herself actually says may the force be
with us
that pretty much settles it right what's
interesting about this is until now Jin
has been presented as an every woman a
plucky heroine with no special powers
that the audience can relate to an
ordinary person doing something
extraordinary kind of like Luke but alas
she's special destined to do something
important that will have implications
for years to come there's nothing wrong
with that
and if anything it will be exciting to
watch that moment when she finally
realizes that the force works through
her again kind of like Luke well we
don't have long to wait before rogue Wan
hits our screens so maybe we can confirm
or bust some of these myths for more
videos like this one make sure to LIKE
and subscribe to GameSpot and we'll see
you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]